[Music]
welcome to this special edition of
hannity i'm tammy bruce in for sean and
tonight the most incompetent
administration in american history
strikes again now a dire baby formula
shortage is causing panic understandably
among parents nationwide of course there
is no mystery behind this new crisis way
back in february biden's own fda halted
production at one of the largest baby
formula plants in the country but today
our very indignant president declared
that there's just no way he could have
seen this coming watch this
a lot of parents are watching about baby
formula if you have a message to those
parents that you can share while they're
listening well uh
three questions i'll answer the baby
formula question because all of a sudden
it's on the front page of every
newspaper and that's important that i'd
be responded to should you have taken
those steps sooner before parents got to
these shelves and couldn't find formula
if we'd been better mind readers i guess
we could have but we moved as quickly as
the problem became apparent to us
and
we have to move with caution as well as
speed
wow because it's on the cover of the
newspapers he's got to deal with it now
instead of fixing this nightmare the
administration and their allies are
deflecting blame a washington post
fact-checker
called the shortage a faux outrage
yesterday jan saki told concerned
parents to call a doctor
on twitter bette midler she should know
suggested that americans quote try
breastfeeding it's free and available on
demand
meanwhile eric swalwell blame gop
congresswoman elise stefanik and accused
her of wanting to starve small children
because she raised concerns over the
government's stockpile of baby formula
earmarked for illegal immigrants
and on the view sunny hostin blamed the
united states for not having federally
paid maternity leave yeah that's the
culprit watch this
i think the fault lies in the fact that
we have terrible
uh
maternity leave because a lot of women
would love to be able to stay home and
breastfeed their children and take care
of their children and the fact of the
matter is we can't do that because we
have very limited maternity leave and we
have to immediately go back to work to
take care of our families and feed our
families and the government doesn't
support us in that
my goodness it just never ends now while
liberals deflect and distract this
crisis is not going away in fact no one
at the white house seems to know when
this serious problem will be resolved
check this out
kate at this point do you does the white
house consider this a crisis
well i don't think it's about a label
isn't part of this figuring out what the
timeline is when you think
it's going to be fixed
as and and we are working to do it as
quickly as possible i'm not you know i
it is in i'm not going to stand here and
tell your audience uh that i can give
you a hard timeline that i can't give
you gosh yeah even cnn there seems
unhappy those are good questions and
they didn't get answers hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else